Hello. This session has a pretty big title.
It says 'What I did to get some cool air
10 minutes before getting home after work in the hot summer.'
Now, whether or not it was successful
will be found out in 25 minutes.
It's a short period of time, but I'll try my best.
Let me introduce myself first. I'm Justin.
I work for Microsoft as a cloud advocate.
You can see my Twitter and Github profiles here.
If you're curious about my personal information, please check out the introduction page below.
And I'm almost living in twitter,
그리고 좀 거의 이제 트위터에서 지박령으로 활동을 하고 있기 때문에
so if you're in twitter too,
I'd like you to greet me there as well.
I think I need to give you a brief introduction to why I started this project first.
Because you might wonder how JavaScript and home automation are related at all,
first of all, around the end of May,
I tried live coding with a guest
for building a smart-home IoT using Azure Functions
on my own Youtube channel.
And a lot of people were interested in it.
Now, if you're curious about it, see the address down here,
you can go, and check it out. You can also see other things there, so you'd better take a look.
But the test taker was so witty in it,
so I was very encouraged as well.
Because I have lived abroad for a long time, and came back to Korea not so long ago,
and I knew that summer in Korea is very hot
considering the time before I went abroad,
I mean, I knew that Korea was very hot because it was getting hotter than before,
like the news says that it's going to be incredibly hot,
something like that,
so I was worried. But right after that session,
I was like 'Oh? Well, I have a raspberry pi at home.
so let me make one too. I'll try to make it similar.'
So,
if I'm going for it anyway,
I wanted to make it better.
Like I thought of adding some more features and upgrading it.
That's how motivated I was.
But, like always, we begin something with enough motivation,
but there are some obstacles here and there along the way, right?
So it wasn't as easy as I thought.
on the way from start to finish,
there're a lot of problems here and there, and I wanted to beat head against a wall,
but I somehow made it after all that.
I did make it. It was really difficult.
So, to organize, and to share it with you,
I'm here with you today.
First of all, this is home automation.
To implement home automation, there are a few things that you need to do with your hardware.
I think I need to explain a little bit about the overall architecture.
I had an old Raspberry Pi that was now rolling around in my house.
As far as I know, Raspberry pi is out to version 4.
My model was an old model that came out around 2014.
Yes, it was about Raspberry Pi 2 model B.
It's still working well.
So we don't have to buy a new raspberry pi, let's just use it.
So I decided to just use the old model.
And my ultimate goal is to get all the remote controls at home.
Let's integrate with one of these raspberry pies and make an all-round remote control.
Well, that was the goal.
And most of the remote controls at home are infrared.
So we needed a sensor module to attach to a raspberry pie that could replace the infrared signal on the remote.
I needed an infrared sensor module.
적외선 센서 모듈이 필요했어요.
Fortunately, these sensor modules are already in Amazon and online shopping malls.
But fortunately, I got it from someone I knew.
I didn't force him to do it. I just...
Yes, he gave it to me, so I got it and used it.
If you look at this picture, there's a receiver here, right?
This is ir sensor. So it's the part that receives the infrared signal.
This is the part that now sends out infrared signals.
So what this infrared light signal is used for example,
We're going to have raspberry pi,
It's what I need to store my remote controller data.
Now, the thing is, we're going to use the remote data that's stored.
It's like a raspberry pi is a real remote control.
That's what happens. I don't need two buttons.
So, this infrared sensor worked really well now.
So this is the big, big, big... It's a rough architecture.
Uh, Raspberry pi played the role of a remote first,
I built an api server in here with node.js.
As an api server with node.js,
This server works as if it were a remote control.
And now I'm going to put this on my home network.
Rather than open this home network to the public at once,
Only the necessary parts. I tunneled the api part a little bit so that it could be used.
Then I encapsulated the tunnel data
needed for this tunneling. And I made a facade with an Azure Function.
I've encapsulated it so that everything can be done if you just run the function outside.
Now, let's get the Azure Functions running on mobile apps.
I rolled it with a power app and a power automate. For our users,
like me and my family, if you just run the power app,
저나 저희 가족 같은 저희 사용자 입장에서는 파워 앱만 실행을 시키면은
I've been working on home appliances so that I can turn the air conditioner off and on.
I think that's the rough architecture now.
So let's start with the first steps that I did to implement this architecture as it is.
The first thing I had to do was to change this raspberry pi to a remote control.
Because, as I said for a second, my ultimate goal was to make Raspberry pi a universal remote control.
It was supposed to change this, but in order to do that,
You're saying you've installed the infrared sensor module and now you have to set it up?
Actually, this part was really hard.
Because, you know, it's okay to set it up, but you set it up
There's, like, a little. The methods of setting things up,
It was very different. Every resources are old.
It didn't fit my situation. But even if these old info
are from around 2018, 2019. It didn't fit my situation.
So I'm pretty much going to use this.
What should I say, Trial and error? I've been going through trial and error
I tried this and that and that, so I succeeded.
Sometimes on the menu. If you go with the manual on the Internet,
The module that receives the sensor works well, but the module that you send doesn't work.
On the other hand, the sending module works, but the receiving module doesn't work.
So I tried to do something about it and it worked.
It works well, so I don't want to forget this, so I'm going to do it again and again.
It happened by chance, so I re-produced it a few times just in case.
So I thought, "Oh, this is how it works!" So I recorded it well.
I wrote it on my blog. So I'll share it with you later on.
That's how the work is done. Based on the old info, I worked hard.
The work up to here is, the infrared sensors started working.
Now, the second thing I have to do is,
Now I need to register with my remote raspberry pi.
But the funny thing is, there's a database for remote control.
There's a database that has all the remote control data in the world.
There's a repository called lirc-remotes in Source Forge.
There are all kinds of remote controls here.
But the problem is that the latest update is in 2018.
It was two years ago. But that doesn't mean it has every remote
It says that it covers every remote control in the world, but if you actually search,
There are things about famous brands, but not all.
For example, things that are famous only in Korea. There's nothing.
So, even though I searched, my remote control wasn't there.
So I couldn't use this database.
So I had to make my own remote control data.
The funny thing about making remote control data was,
Infrared sensors are signals. It's a light signal. It's a number-converting process.
It wasn't as easy as I thought because...
Infrared is light, isn't it? But when you do that, there's always light around it.
Depending on the amount of light, this infrared signal keeps getting interrupted.
So even if you press the same button,
you might not get the same data. So I'll show you this.
This was actually a capture of the data.
I run it with a program called mode2. So every time I press a button,
So whenever I press a button the number blocks are increased one by one. It comes out like this.
So if you look here, there's a number block here, right?
The larger the block, the more complicated the remote control is.
The more complex the remote control is, the larger the number block.
The simpler the remote control, the smaller the block of these numbers.
So my remote control is somewhere in the middle.
Anyway, so I got the remote control signal.
After catching it, what I made was a TV remote control.
Because the TV remote control was the simplest one in my house.
First of all, I made this.
I actually ran it like this. If you look here, you can see the command, right?
irsend SEND_ONCE tv SWITCH_ON. I sent the order like this.
Then the TV in the back turns on. It turns on, and It's a smart TV,
so it takes time to boot up. I've already sent a signal,
It took me a while to turn it in the back on.
When it turns on like this, Eventually,
You can see the Netflix screen.
And then next time, If you send again through the command
irsend SEND_ONCE TV SWITCH_OFF, the television will be turned off. Okay, it's off, right?
And so I was able to see that the remote control app actually works.
So, of the whole architecture, we're going to be able to do that
We've gone so far as to attach the raspberry pi to the Wi-Fi and use it as a remote control.
There's a long way to go, right?
I'm sure some of you are curious about this.
Okay, then the TV's fine. OK. What about the air conditioner?
I'm sure some of you are wondering about the air conditioner.
That's not important, so let's move on. First, I will continue with the TV remote control.
Now that we're done with the remote control, we're going to actually control it through the app.
Let me tell you a little bit about that. It's a remote control for now.
You just sent me the word 'irsend SEND_ONCE TV SWITCH_ON.
They're amazing, aren't they?
People have already made it into an NPM package.
So I use it to use a very simple remote control server. I'm going to create an api server.
So this remote control. using the npm package called lirc_node,
I made it. It's very easy to make.
In fact, the remote control module is a very simple code, about 21 lines long.
So now I'm going to import a package called lirc_node, and if you look at it,
If you look at line 6, there's an end.send_once, device, command.
That device was a TV, and the command was SWITCH_ON now?
So, what you saw in the video clip in front of you,
It's in the same order as the order 'irsend SEND_ONCE TV SWITCH_ON, right?
It's a very intuitive module.
So I created a function called Remote.
You can use that function to create an object called Remote Control, and you can use it to create an object inside it.
We created a function called onSwitchOn, a function called onSwitchOff.
I made the simplest remote controller module.
We can use this to create an api server.
Two end points were created using the express module, express package.
The first endpoint is remote/switchon
The second endpoint is remote/switchoff. So inside the switchon,
I've called a remote.onSwitchOn.
An endpoint called switchoff called a function called onSwitchOff.
This is how we created the api server.
I'm not, in fact, a JavaScript developer anymore.
I'm not a professional developer.
node.js says 'very easy to write'
I tried it. 'Oh really?' Haha, I was a little suspicious.
But in fact, there's only about 21 or 26 lines of code to build this api server.
It's about being able to develop something really fast.
node.js can develop really fast,
When you develop prototyping or Proof Of Concept,
I felt that it was really good.
Now, of course, at the end, are we actually able going to be able to do some enterprise-level work after the POC
It's another question, but it was okay for now.
Let's do this and turn the code.
If you look at the bottom, you can see that there's a visual studio code.
I accessed the raspberry pi, and I started npm there.
Starting to spin up the api server.
api 서버를 돌리기 시작하고 있습니다.
It's back, right? I turned it to port 4000.
So here, I'm going to type in the ip address, port 4000 and send the switchon
It's on now. Let's send the switchoff again.
If you send a switchoff,
If you look at the bottom, you can see SWITCH_OFF, right? It says switchoff.
That means my api server is working right now.
Now, I'm in a home network called 172.30.1.29.
I paged this. In other words, my computer is also in the home network, so I could call it directly.
Now, now, let's go ahead and do this with raspberry pie.
You just created and uploaded a node.js server, right?
Now the home network is working.
Now, it works only within the home network. But our ultimate purpose is to...
Outside the house. I want to run the remote.
We need to expose this Raspberry Pi remote control to the public Internet.
The first way is to expose the entire home network, right?
But you know, this is never recommended for security reasons.
So the second method is tunneling only the applications that are needed. Create a secure tunnel.
So that data can go back and forth only through that tunnel. I'd like to expose them selectively.
This was actually one of the most complicated processes in the past.
Now it's software-proof. Have you ever heard of ngrok? If you use ngrok,
It's very easy to make a secure tunnel like this.
Just in time, for raspberry pi, ngrok now has an application.
Download it to raspberry pie and run it.
And if you link that to node.js api,
Because of this ngrok, only certain api servers are exposed to the Internet.
Then I'll show you like this. Let's look at the screen.
Now, if you look at the bottom left, you can see it again.
Now I run the api server. Can you see the execution?
Api went back. Let me look to the right for a second. Now, if you look to the right,
I'm in the raspberry pi, and now, ngrock and http 4000 port.
It's done like this. So, http, we're going to open the api server with only 4000 ports.
And then randomly, the Url that ngrok makes is caught.
So if you take this url and write it down instead of the ip address and port number, it'll be like this.
So you can run it outside of your home network.
Did you turn on the switch with the remote control?
So this time, I've turned the switch off again. So this is how you do it, random.
With the url that ngrok makes,
Now you can run it outside of your home network.
So we've been trying to get access to the home network from the public Internet.
We even implemented a secure channel.
Well, then it's about done.
It's almost done. What's left is. Then, on the public cloud.
How can I get in this direction from the cloud? Now I have to make this part for you know what?
As you can see, ngrok has a free version and a paid version.
It doesn't matter if it's a paid version, but we use a free version for now, right?
If this is a free version, the address changes every time you run ngrock.
So it's very difficult to use it directly.
For direct external use. That's why I wanted to protect this channel.
And then to prevent the random url that keeps changing like this ngrok.
I decided to make a facade.
I could have made a facade with nodejs and Azure function, too.
If you're curious about how to make an Azure Function with JavaScript,
If you go to aka.ms/jsconf/azfunc-nodejs,
There are a lot of references. So it's very easy to make.
It would be nice to take a look. It's very easy to make.
It's about 22 lines long.
As you can see, through Query String and Request Body,
TV. Device. That's TV here, right? Power, switch on, off.
I got these two data. next time
There is a variable value called REMOTE_BASE_URI.
The value of the environment variable is the url that the ngrok accepts, the constant change of ngrok, the end point.
We'll combine these two, and we'll take the url and we'll go through the axios.
Now, call the node.js api server.
So you made the code now? It's very easy to make now. in this way
We can encapsulate the random url that ngrok makes.
Let me show you. in the same way
We're going to run the api server with npm.
On the right, run ngrok
그 다음에 오른쪽에서 ngrok으로 돌립니다?
Then a different url was made.
그러면 아까와 다른 url이 만들어 졌죠.
Now, we've just created a random url, and we've distributed it to Azure.
You put it in the environment variable.
Once we put it in, and now we're running it again.
If I do this, you're ready for the next function, right? The address of the Azure Function is...
It says fncap-rpi-proxy-krc.
I'm going to take this address and actually put it. So...
With Query String, device is TV and power is on. It turned on like this.
Now you can see that it's switched on. If you look at the bottom right, you can see the result is still coming out, right?
Now, we went to power off this time off. I turned off the TV when I turned it off.
So if you look down here, you can see that switch off, then the endpoint, remote/switchoff, was called, right?
Like this, I made the facade with the azure function.
So, I made a facade.
In fact, it doesn't really matter if we go this far.
I don't really care, but here's one problem, not a problem, but a problem.
It's already made.
It's already been made, Nevertheless, in order for me to turn
the air conditioner on and off outside,
I'm supposed to open a web browser or Postman or something like that.
Rather, why don't we make mobile apps a little easier?
So I decided to make a mobile app.
It's hard to make a mobile app.
For example, you have to open up a React Native thing, do it, publish it, and so on.
It's too much trouble to do that.
So I thought about how I could make a mobile app very easily.
And now there's a power platform.
There's a power platform that Microsoft is talking about.
It's incredibly easy to create applications.
If you want to know more about the power platform,
If you go to aka.ms/jsconf/power-platform, you'll find out more.
Let me tell you about Power Automate first.
Power automates basically manage workflows.
The only thing this AutoMate Workflow does is, the Azure Function. You know the facade I made earlier?
All I have to do is call the facade.
So I'm gonna call the end point, put the api key in,
And then you get the device and power from the mobile app and you send it right away.
This is the only role .
So there's a very simple workflow, right?
And then, this is the power app screen.
Power apps are very easy to make, and if you know how to do things like Excel,
There's a lot of funtion in the excel, right? Excel functions
You can use it like you're using those Excel functions.
So there is Power AutoMate, HomeAppliancesRemoteController which I made earlier.
As you can see here,
There's an on button, there's an off button,
Send variables like this when you press this on button.
When you press the off button, 'TV off'. Send it like this.
If you send it now, the results are actually like this.
The television turned on when I pressed the on button.
If you press the off button, it will be off now. This is what happens.
So I've finished writing the application.
That's how I organized the entire architecture.
Then I'll actually run it.
Now, the api server is running again, right?
Then, make a new url with ngrok.
I'm going to save this as an old one as a new one as an environmental variable.
Save it again.
Well, it's saved.
After this was saved,
Then, let's go to the next one.The facade is done.
I'm already using the Power app to call a function.
I just took a screenshot of my app.
So I'm actually running my app.
You turned it to remote control, right? When I actually pressed the on button,
Let's take a look. If you press it, you'll see the results on the right side.
Now, it becomes switch on, it becomes switch on.
You see the result turned on? Now, I've pressed off this time.
You can see that switch off, switch off, and the result is switch off.
You can actually see the apps working like this.
So I actually did this in front of the TV.
Does it really work? Does it really work? I've tried it.
So, I guess we're going to turn it on here.
All right, turn it on and press the on button.
As I mentioned earlier, it's a smart TV.
It's a smart TV, so it's kind of smart. It turns on slowly, right? I guess you have a lot of thoughts.
So, it's on, right? After it's on, at the back, it's...
You'll see the Netflix screen for a moment.
I just showed you a little bit to make sure that the TV is actually on.
Okay, now its on
Now, let's press the off button. If you press the off button,
Now, you'll see that the television is going to turn off.
It's off, right? So, the screen is turned off.
I actually filmed myself turning the TV on and off through my phone.
So I run the JavaScript app on the iot device.
So we've done a lot of home automation.
In the meantime, I learned a lot of things. Actually, I had a hard time, but I learned a lot of things.
First of all, I made the remote control data.
If I had already had the remote control data, I wouldn't have done this.
Because I didn't, I actually started making remote control data.
Second, I created the api app with node.js.
The fact that the api itself is very easy to make, I really liked it.
And then, thirdly, use ngrok to create secure tunneling.
I tried to expose my home network on the Internet.
And the fourth thing is, we encapsulated the secure tunnel with the Azure Function, and we encapsulated it.
I've been working on it so it's hard to tell from the outside.
Lastly, I even showed developing mobile apps using power apps and power automate.
But, actually, the consumer electronics are...
If your home appliances now support Wi-Fi,
Actually, I don't think I had to do this kind of work.
But now, there's still a lot of appliances.
We're still using the remote control, infrared.
If you're still curious, you might want to try something like this.
And the funny thing is that everything I needed has already been done before
So I just took it and put it together. That's all I've ever done. Actually.
That's all I've prepared.
Now I want to give you homework instead.
So just in case, I have a raspberry pi. Or I'm planning to buy a raspberry pi.
So if you say, "I want to try this!"
These two links are on my blog, so please read them and follow them.
So 10 minutes before I get home after work in the hot summer.
I told you about the story of how I worked to turn on the air conditioner
Thank you.
Well, the title is air conditioner. It's still air conditioner. But the title is air conditioner.
I've never told you about the air conditioner.
Actually, I failed to make the remote control data for the air conditioner.
Everything else is ready. Everything else is done, but I couldn't run the air conditioner.
Unfortunately, I've registered every remote control in my house
Only the air conditioner didn't work. I don't know why.
That's why it's still hot, isn't it? It's a little hot. It's very hot.
So the title is "home electronics," "out of the house."
Slightly change it to run it on your cell phone.
I'll end this session. Thank you.